OK.
Let's get into audience questions for the
week first one.
Hey, David, with everything going on with
Corona virus, can the United States federal
government forcibly quarantine people and
not allow them to leave their homes?
As usual?
This is a question that has a number of different
answers.
Part of it, because we have state and local
government.
It's also a question that I would prefer we
not actually test the limits of.
Let's not make it necessary to find out if
the federal government can forcibly require
people to stay in their homes.
I think we're all much better off going along
with what it is that we are doing to try to
stop the spread of Corona virus.
I know that it sucks.
I want to be going to places.
I want to go to cafes.
I want to be hanging out with people.
I get it.
OK.
But we've all got to do our part time to put
up that.
Pull up your big boy pants and do your part.
But now let's explore it realistically.
Sort of lockdowns would be happening at a
state level rather than the federal government
level.
More than likely, again, we can talk about
these scenarios where martial law is declared
and the government sends the military.
But more realistically, this would be happening
at the state level.
So we actually have an example here in Massachusetts
from the Boston Marathon bombing years ago.
And the Scott Sillman Silliman, who is emeritus
director of the Center on Law, Ethics and
National Security at Duke Law School, says
lockdowns really are voluntary.
The governor says they want people to shelter
in place and shelter in place can be used
in a pandemic.
It can be used if there's dangerous people
on the loose.
As was the case with the Boston Marathon bombing.
And you're essentially saying stay where you
are either to not expose yourself to a violent
criminals out on the street, to not expose
yourself or others to a virus or disease of
some kind.
Shelter in place that is different than a
state of emergency, which then has more sort
of financial implications in terms of states
being able to mobilize and accept certain
resources from the federal government.
And in either case, you can try to institute
penalties of fines or prison for people who
violate some of these decrees.
More likely, they take place with violations
of curfews and things associated with states
of emergency than with requests to shelter
in place.
So, again, it really depends on in which state
this happens.
As we already know, there's a huge partisan
divide with coronavirus.
Republicans are far less worried about it.
Republicans are far less likely to be modifying
their behavior as a result.
Republicans three times more likely to be
hanging out in bars and restaurants and ignoring
all of the recommendations from the CDC.
You would, I would imagine, also see different
states handle this differently.
And as a result, you would likely start to
see some trends in terms of states that are
doing better and worse in terms of the virus.
My recommendation is let's not make it necessary
to test the legal limits of recommendations
that people stay home.
Now, from a practical perspective, if you
close down schools, ban gatherings of more
than 25 people, closed down bars and restaurants
other than for takeout and delivery, if banks
close a lot of public facing, businesses close
and you shut down public transportation, which
can be done more relevant in cities, you are
going to get a lot of people who just aren't
going to go anywhere because where the hell
are they going to go?
And that's also becoming a reality, certainly,
certainly here in Massachusetts.
But let's let's cooperate.
Let's do the right thing.
Let's understand that even if we think when
we go out, we're not doing anything.
Imagine that when you go out, you're putting
an 80 year old or a kid who's immunocompromised
in danger.
I don't want to be doing that.
I don't want to participate in that.
So I'm limiting what I'm doing.